What happened to the heroes
of the "Predator" movies?
Why are Predators so attracted to heat?
What's the reasoning behind their methods?
Watch for even more questions we
may never know the answers to.
To date, no character — human or otherwise
— has been featured in more than one film
in the Predator franchise. The
lack of any recurring characters
is one of the franchise’s strengths,
but it does leave one curious as to
how each human moves on with their
life after surviving the Yautja.
Each sequel has attempted to have
Schwarzenegger reprise his role
as Alan Dutch Schaefer, but he's refused, leaving
the character's fate hazy for decades. In 2020,
Arnold gave in for the 2020 video game, Preda
tor: Hunting Grounds. This game includes audio
journals accounting for Dutch's actions
between 1987 and the game's 2025 setting.
According to the journals, Dutch has been
traveling the world, searching for more evidence
of the Yautja's presence on Earth. He teams
up with the Other Worldly Life Forms Program,
the shady government agency from Predator 2. As
the Earth gets hotter, Predators visit frequently,
leading to repeated battles between
Dutch and the Yautja. By 2025,
he's been rebuilt using Yautja tech,
fearless and fit, despite his advanced age.
"This thing is hunting us....all of us"
Across the Predator franchise, the Yautja
have demonstrated a common modus operandi
that includes a few signature kills. No
Predator film would be complete, for instance,
without someone having their skull and
spine ripped out of their bodies in one
swift motion. The Yautja remove skulls
and spines to display them as trophies,
and add bones to their armor to show off
their killing prowess. Their reasoning behind
flaying a victim and leaving their bodies
behind, however, is a little more murky.
The intention behind hanging their skinned
prey is still the subject of debate among
fans. The Yaujta do not appear to collect
the skins they remove from their victims,
so it's clearly the bodies themselves that are
important to the ritual. It's likely that these
bodies are left as a form of intimidation
to throw their next opponents off balance.
There's also a theory that only those considered
easy prey are flayed, as they are unworthy of
having their bones collected as trophies. "Not
only did I kill this guy," this action says,
according to this theory, "but I even
had time to rip his skin off afterwards.
If you don't want the same thing to happen
to you, you'd better be more entertaining."
In Predator, rebel Anna tells the mercenaries that
their stalker matches the description of, quote,
"the demon who makes trophies of man," from
local folklore. The stalkers are said to only
appear during the hottest summers. When
the Yautja return to Earth in Predator 2,
it's during a record-breaking heat wave in LA.
Predator: Hunting Grounds implies that
climate change has made the Earth a more
attractive place to hunt. The natural
assumption to make is that the heat
mirrors that of the Yautja's natural
habitat, and that a hot summer is the
time during which the Earth is most
habitable for both humans and Yautja.
As the series progresses, the Yautja's preference
in climate is less emphasized. Alien vs. Predator
reveals some Yautja visit every 100 years — in
Antarctica. Furthermore, Aliens vs. Predator:
Requiem is set in Colorado, and the story is
explicitly set near Halloween in The Predator.
This doesn't mean that the Predators don't still
prefer the heat, but it does remove its necessity.
In Predator 2, Mike Harrigan discovers an
alien hunter, nicknamed "City Hunter" by fans,
has been on an undercover killing spree. The
film concludes with Harrigan chasing the Predator
to his ship and killing him. However, other
Yautja have been watching all of this unfold,
hidden by cloaking technology. They retrieve
the dead Predator's body and leave LA.
Out of this group of Yautja, only one is seen
making kills. It's unclear if the others simply
haven't been caught, remain on the ship the entire
time, or if they are here on other business.
Only one member of the Los Angeles hunting party —
their leader, Greyback — ever appears again in the
Predator expanded universe, and that story does
not account for his whereabouts during Predator 2.
" You can't see the eyes of the
demon, until him come calling."
At the end of Predator 2 Harrigan receives a
trophy from the Yautja leader for killing the
City Hunter. It's a flintlock pistol
labeled "Raphael Adolini, 1715."
This gift is evidence that the Yautja
have been hunting on Earth for centuries.
The 1996 comic Predator: 1718 depicts the original
encounter between the Yautja known as Greyback and
pirate captain Raphael Adolini. Andolini,
a criminal with a righteous moral compass,
wants to return a chest of gold to the church
from which it was stolen. His crew objects and
mutinies. Greyback surprisingly joins Adolini
and together they defeat his traitorous crew.
Andolini is lethally injured and offers
Greyback his pistol as a tribute.
The protagonist of Alien vs. Predator is Lex
Woods, an expert ice climber hired to guide
an expedition to explore an ancient temple beneath
an Antarctic island. Lex survives being picked off
by the xenomorphs and Yautja, and allies herself
with the Yautja hunter Scar. She receives a Yautja
Combistick weapon as a trophy, and much of her
fate after the Yautja craft departs is unknown.
Lex's arc hasn't been revisited or referenced
in any expanded universe material. However,
there is a piece of evidence that
Lex, or at least her weapons,
were recovered from the Antarctic
battle site. In 2018's The Predator,
Dr. Casey Brackett explores Project Stargazer's
headquarters and finds a case containing Lex's
spear. This seems to confirm that Alien vs.
Predator is still part of the Predator canon.
The action of Alien vs. Predator takes place
inside an ancient temple in Antarctica,
the site of a ritual where adolescent
Yautja prove themselves against the
universe's ultimate killing machines. Inside
the temple lies an enslaved xenomorph queen,
kept in hibernation for a century at
a time. A few hours before a hunt,
she's forced to lay eggs so that the Yautja
will have something to test themselves against.
In 2004's ritual, the queen gets wise and
instructs her children to set her free by
melting her chains with their acidic blood. At
the film's climax, the queen escapes the temple
into the abandoned town, and battles on the ice
with Lex and Scar, the last human and Yautja.
They successfully chain her to a heavy iron
vat and push it into the freezing water.
The queen drops to the bottom of the sea
and is presumably no longer a threat.
Other films in the Alien series have shown that
xenomorphs are capable of enduring the freezing
airless vacuum of space. It is likely the queen
could survive these conditions for a while or
even forever! Nevertheless, the Antarctic queen
has never reappeared in the franchise's canon.
Aliens vs. Predator: Requiem picks
up where the first AvP leaves off,
with a xenomorph chestburster emerging from
Scar's corpse. This xenomorph has taken on
many of the traits of its Yautja host
to become the even deadlier "Predalien".
When the Predalien crash-lands a spacecraft
loaded with xenomorph eggs in Colorado,
another Predator, Wolf, is set loose to
clean up the mess. Wolf battles with the
Predalien and a hoard of xenomorphs, but
this battle is moot — the story ends with
the US government dropping a nuke on the village,
destroying almost all evidence of the conflict.
In the final scene, US Army Colonel Stevens
presents Ms. Yutani with a plasma pistol
fashioned by Wolf. Yutani seems to
have plans for the pistol that are,
quote, "not for this world." It's implied that
Yutani plans to reverse-engineer the technology
to advance her company's interests in
space, leading to the Weyland-Yutani
Corporation's dominance of space freight and
xenomorph experimentation in the Alien series.
Requiem doesn't have a sequel so we don't have
many details on what will happen next. Also,
the release of Prometheus in 2012 detached the
Alien franchise from the continuity of AvP,
leaving the future of the
Yutani Corporation uncertain.
2010's Predators takes the action off Earth
entirely, and follows a group of humans who
are each abducted and transported to a planet
that is a massive game preserve. Each of the
human captives is a predator in their own
right — a soldier, a convict, a gangster,
and so on — but most of them are no match for
their pursuers, who are bigger and badder than
any Yautja seen previously. They're picked off
one by one until the only survivors are American
mercenary Royce and IDF sniper Isabelle. Predators
ends with Isabelle and Royce victorious over
their hunters, but still stranded on the planet,
where another hunting season is about to begin.
Unlike most protagonists in the Predator
franchise, Isabelle and Royce received a
follow-up story immediately, in the form of
an official sequel comic: 2010's Predators:
Preserve the Game. The one-shot comic
picks up two months after the film,
as Royce and Isabelle continue to pick
off Predators and salvage their gear.
The Yautja determine Royce is a worthy opponent,
and gifts him his own set of Predator armor to
wear in one-on-one battle against a four-armed
super-Yautja. But Royce learns to depend on
someone else for a change and sets himself
up as bait so that Isabelle can get the kill.
They remain trapped on the planet, waiting
for an opportunity to hijack a starship.
In The Predator, another Yautja comes to Earth.
But this time, he's not here to hunt — he's on the
run from the larger, genetically-enhanced Upgrade
Predator. The Fugitive crash-lands in Mexico,
but not before ejecting a pod containing
some precious cargo. By the end of the film,
both Predators are dead. With the help
of young linguistic genius Rory McKenna,
US military scientists are able to determine
that the rebel Predator came to Earth to deliver
the humans a weapon: A powered suit of armor
called the Predator-Killer. Rory's father,
Army Ranger Quinn McKenna, plans to wear it
in battle next time the Yautja come calling.
But why did the Fugitive Predator decide to
give this weapon to humanity in the first place?
Does it have anything to do with the human DNA
found in his blood? If he's here to help us,
he's got a funny way of showing it, as he kills
nearly every person he sees during his time on
our planet. His apparently benevolent intentions
are only revealed in the final scene of the film,
a teaser for a sequel that has never happened.
This last-minute twist may be the result of
the film's reshoots, which reportedly changed
a great deal of the film's overall plot. In
fact, in one of the three filmed endings,
the Fugitive's cargo pod contains Ellen
Ripley, heroine of the Alien films.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Predator
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.